she said your grandma almost killed me i
was like what
they get to this boat and by that time
my mother she was starving to death they
had no idea when they were going to get
food or water again if they were ever
going to get to safety my grandfather
sort of looks to my grandmother and says
i think we have to do something about
sunny ultimately what he was saying was
we need to throw her in the water throw
her into the sea and drown her
she ultimately decided okay maybe that
is the right decision so they decided to
go to the uppermost deck of the ship
where there were not a lot of people
everyone's crying at that point right a
couple of american gis who were also on
the ship because it was a u.s naval ship
they sort of saw okay what what's going
on over there they approached my
grandparents ultimately they realized
what was happening was that my mother
was starving and she needed food and so
he reached into his pocket and pulled
out a chocolate bar and put it into my
mom's hand that is what saved her life